i hear a skeleton skeletor rolling
around
so that's also phoenix that's the stuff
that if you and suiculate
that's the stuff if you put on a
lava it regenerates
oh this this is so great i'm gonna have
to decide like what type of stuff i want
and what
i think we got some more so cholera or
whatever this [ __ ] i don't know
i don't know bro you need like six
furnaces
i hear your skeleton
please
hear my auto switch
if you can't tell it's switching to the
sword don't worry if it doesn't look
like it is it is don't worry
don't worry
oh my gosh so much ore
get some phoenix on the ground over
there
i was gonna say i was like it seems like
i'm getting near a stack of stack of
iron
oh my gosh this is so awesome bro
the gems mod i highly suggest getting it
even if you don't want the gems because
i think it makes coal and iron like a
lot more
uh
frequently spawning
i mean so much coal oh my gosh
almost two and a half
stacks probably going to start heading
out soon
yeah probably good sort of starter wheat
farm even though i want carrots
characters like
bread replenishes two and a half carrot
replenishes two but a bread costs three
wheat and a carrot is just a carrot
so carrots are much better
or that's been my experience
give me your stuff
your skeleton
i just got all these intersecting minds
okay probably shouldn't i think this is
the end of it yeah you can say i was
gonna explore but it's the end of it so
it's chill it's chills
it's chills cools beans bros
oh that would have been so awesome if i
made it all the way
break you
and you
and you and you and you
and you
so my health isn't going to be
regenerating oh i'm out of torches dang
it didn't even realize that okay i'm
going to kill you
oh my gosh why is my armor so good he
shoots me i don't even take any damage
oh yeah
okay we're gonna need escape and because
i don't have any torches i don't really
want i really want to make more torches
so i'm going to try finding my old
oh we're going to get you though
and i can't see and the creeper might
freaking attack me
all right uh
can we get out here
break you
oh it's from 26 cressila 50 iron 21
malachite four citrine six jade 10
cigalite and one a gate
a jate probably said those are all
terribly but i don't care
all right we got a
oh like iron on the ground
so this is the on my staircase
my second circus you can see the
non-effects of smooth lighting so they
turned it down
and we're gonna find a way to get out
oh frick
i heard the bat's wing slap and it
sounded like like like an ender dragon
or something
kind of scared me
could get out i think i'm gonna try
getting out that way
dirt be a bridge
i'll pick up this iron too
because why'd you ever leave iron behind
and you should you can turn all the
these ores into blocks and you can also
use them to color sand
so
yes
oh we've made it out awesome
now where's my house oh there's my sugar
cane farm oh above my house okay awesome
hello chicken there's my mind
all right first thing first
two more you bad boys at least
boom boom boom
torch
i want to put you up
now
uh probably put
why not put everything in there
i can afford it because i'm all rich on
coal
oh rich on these here cool
got four furnaces i'll have a stack of
calling them
all right then i'm gonna cook the
malachite and the crystallite the none
of the other stuff it has enough
to uh
warrants
okay i'm gonna make a
blocks chest
yes okay
i saw my goods and all my blocks blocks
would be above so gravel
i want to keep that wood keep
cobble
no this is block shun
so you can take all block block block
block block block block block block
block block my voice crack a little bit
there did you catch it
did you be honest did you catch my voice
cracking
dirt glass oh i can't fit it
okay block
block block no
now i didn't put anything in this one i
can put some phoenix adore
yeah chrysler killa
malachite
iron yeah the textures are a little bit
funky but
it's chill you see if i have a
i take some of that glass
and i don't need a crafting table to do
this but can i do that
now what what the hell what am i doing
i can't i can't do it with a glass i
have to do with
sand i need sand for it though dang it
this is like so i love this it makes it
so open
so we need to pick up some more of this
here sand
luckily we have like a ginormo beach
it's like i'm going to try
sound
oh my gosh that is some loud loud sounds
how loud is this for you guys
that is quite loud
i need to kill some cows too
say like uh place this hand and place
that
no yeah i have no idea never mind forget
it stress just forget it i need to turn
into dies wait wait
you know i'm just um maybe it's a cook i
don't know i need somehow you turn into
dust one sec
bring you back down to speed
somehow you turn into dust and yeah i
don't know
phoenix phoenix it looks so cool
let's see uh
phoenix pickaxe
um
let's make it should i make a picture
citroen looks freaking cool
yeah so it looks seems like chrysler
killer and malachi are pretty common so
i'm gonna make a
sword
also the swords have different textures
like
it's a train sword
let's go test this on a mob
i gotta be careful because i don't want
to die because i have 24 levels
gotta start a cow farm soon
for that i need wheat that is the reason
i need wheat
i'm not hard
wait does it switch to my
well this is a good way to check
which one does it switch it switches oh
so i think i mean citrine is better than
iron
well this will kill in one hit yeah all
the switches was a switch to the thing
does most damage oh we got a pack of
skelets
let's go skillets this is going to be
difficult
since
ah fire aspect oh my gosh
that is not good okay i'm making no i'm
going for the water
nope nope
one sec guys
bye